yes what's up this is andrew for
trainsenses.com
as usual i'm here to make some technical
analysis and show you all the different
tools and techniques that i like to use
at work to set up my trades
and make some money so today is saturday
and it's a very sunny day in hong kong i
didn't go out yesterday because i knew
that
i would wake up this morning and i would
feel like hey
i want to make an update on amc so let's
get into it
[Music]
all right guys so uh let's start on the
first time frame as usual and let's sum
up a bit
what happened this week so i did my last
video
i think around tuesday something like
this
and i told you guys that we gonna have
some conservation
that we are in the third wave of my
third wave here
so maybe let me for those who haven't
watched this video i was basically
telling you guys
that this whole consolidation here that
lasts you know for the past two or three
months is over
and that we are actually right now in
the third waves all right so moves up
developing five waves one two three four
fives
and the third wave is usually the most
impulsive and the strongest one
so here this to me looks very much like
a third wave
and in this third wave usually we are
extended which means we having five
waves as well
and we are in the third of this third
wave so i was expecting here guys you
can go and check my video
a bit of consolidation and i told you
that that this deep is
nothing so this is for me completely
normal you can see that here
we got rejected from the 14.5 level
15 level roughly if you check on the
daily time frame we didn't even trade
here because this
this was after market actually so
technically it should not be taken into
account in my analysis
but on the hour time frame i see it so
let's take it into account
and yeah this is to me completely normal
my only little worry guys
is that you know this force wave is not
too deep all right it can even be deeper
it would be fine for me as long as we
stay above the
top here of my wave one so
as long as we stay above this level guys
above 11
roughly 10.9 we not having the force
wave coming into wave one territory
which would
be actually a diagonal so i don't like
to see diagonals at the beginning
of you know in a third wave you can't
have a diagonal all right so this
wouldn't be a third wave
if wave four enters wave one territory
as long as we stay above 11
everything is fine for me my only little
worry guys is that this correction
is not too deep in spots i could go even
lower but it's a bit
long i would like to see some strong
move up coming
earlier because like i told you guys
before
i don't want to see this bearish
divergence coming
here so it was on the daily time frame
i told you guys that we need to have
some strong momentum coming here right
now because i don't want to see here
a higher high with the macd making a
lower high
so between here 17th of march and
here 17th of may the macd is going lower
and the price action
was actually going higher if i check on
the only hourly timeframe
but on the daily time frame it's fine
here so basically i don't have my
divergence
because on the daily timeframe we didn't
make a new high because it was
after market and on the forward time
frame you can see the momentum indicator
is actually trading higher
all right so here we're having a new
high i can put my third wave here
15.8 all right i can see it so i take
into account but the max is going higher
so basically everything is fine we're
not having this divergence
neither on the daily nor on the four
hours time frame
and even less on the hourly time frame
so we are still bullish guys we're still
bullish
but once again let me show you what i
don't really like
is that this i'm not sure what is that
guys to be honest
i'm not sure what is that i'm trying to
identify this
pattern because here i clearly see
kind of a zigzag you know a typical
correction
you know an abc then here we should have
the fifth wave and the fifth wave should
be
itself in five waves all right one two
but then
three four five what is this you know i
don't understand what's that guys
seriously i don't understand but the
same you know
kind of same thing happened here you see
i was telling you guys
exactly at this time we should not break
980
if we break it doesn't look good but
actually we broke it and we had this you
know unidentified
end of pattern you know that was to me
very disturbing and didn't help me to
you know complete my analysis like to
complete my bullish case
and here i'm having the same thing guys
so let's see let's see what kind
of move we're having on uh monday but
for now
what i can tell you is that so this
is still on the table let's see maybe
this is going to be one two like this
you know
the one would be a bit like weird but
fair enough let's let's see what we're
gonna have
for now guys we are still bullish we are
still in the third wave
that is intact for me you can see that
the top of the first wave here
is actually acting very well as support
here if i zoom in little bit so you can
see the maximum level here was 12
15 and all right we closed
slightly below but guys
it acted very well as support here
so once again i don't like to see this
weekly close
at the lower level of the whole week it
doesn't look good
to be honest but it's what we call some
excess all right it's acceptable it's
acceptable as long
as we're having this either we complete
like an abc that is really an abc so
even i would prefer to see something
like this you know so at least you know
i know what is happening you know if i
have something like this
then here we might have you know a
strong rebound and then it's clear
for me we rebound here we're having
actually strong support at 11 30 guys
11 30 is not a new level we had it here
as well
you can see and here we're having the
200 moving average on the hourly
time frame that is coming let me get rid
of this for now
and on the four hours time frame which
is once again guys the most important
time frame
what do we have we having here the 50
period moving average that is coming so
what i'm saying is that 12
should hold but if it doesn't hold it's
all right
we still have a scenario that remains
bullish that is acceptable even if we go
here
it could be like this all right and the
bearish divergence for now didn't occur
so basically i don't have any reason to
actually be bearish here
so i remain bullish and i expect once
again the price action
to make a strong move up very soon guys
very soon
we need it we need the momentum to keep
coming
we need to see the volume picking up
again for now we're still trading
around so this was 200 million shares so
here it's probably
50 70 million shares so it's
we still have some volume but we need to
have a strong move up
a strong like green day with high
volumes and complete
this third wave and of course take back
the 15 level
for good so that's it for me i hope you
guys enjoyed this video
and if you did please don't forget to
click on the sub
like and that button so you're gonna be
the first to know when i upload anything
new and stay close to show i see you
guys